why so I've been waiting for the new
Total Recall trailer to come out it's
out so now we talk about the Total
Recall trailer it's how I roll
Total Recall stars Colin Farrell into
remake of a movie from 1990 starring
Arnold Schwarzenegger in any case the
trailer starts out Colin Farrell wakes
up and Kate Beckinsale's his hot wife
and he wakes up from a nightmare and you
know what nightmare that is is the one
where Arnold was on the surface of Mars
and his eyes were bugging out it looks
all weird and [ __ ] yeah you know that
was a cool part of that movie though I
must say it's gonna sound like I'm just
scraping for cool things I'm really not
trying to but I just think one of the
most impressive parts of the trailer is
how Recall looks stay away from the
first time you know the old movie it was
just like this white lab where you're
like I'm well I think when I'm
unconscious or whatever happens they're
gonna do experiments on me recall in the
new movie kind of looks like something
out of Firefly you know it's really Zen
it looks relaxing you know like you
really kick your feet up there and
you're like okay fine mess with my brain
I'm good with that they got the
waterfalls in the bamboo you know and in
the trailer we find out if you saw the
old movie well you know Colin Farrell
goes to recall because he's kind of
bored with his life he wants a little
bit of excitement so he's like alright
I'll just have them implant a memory in
my brain then it all goes to [ __ ] and
people are trying to kill him and he
knows crazy martial arts
however this cool shot in the trailer
also just annoyed the living hell out of
me I think it looked cool but it also
was one of these shots that was really
overused in the year 2000 like after the
matrix came out every movie had to have
a shot like that it was like oh sweet
you know like the one with Jet Li let's
do that all the time and every other
movie that wasn't the one with Jet Li
but had some sort of sci-fi martial arts
aspect to it had that shot so it almost
looks like the Total Recall remake is
like 10 years past its time at this
point I didn't like feeling like that
when I'm watching a trailer and it being
the first trailer there's not much to
say except Kate Beckinsale's in the
trailer she looks really hot and then
you get jessica biel also yeah Kate
Beckinsale and Jessica Biel are in the
same movie maybe I'm in recall cuz
that's pretty much what I wished for
maybe this is all like in my
subconscious who knows but among all of
the action that you got and Colin
Farrell is a really good actor I think
he'll be good in the movie the movie
looks like it could be cool but it
doesn't look like anything special I
mean of all the movies coming out this
summer that I'm holding my breath for
it's not Total Recall
Avengers Dark Knight Rises spider-man
Prometheus yeah it's it's eclipsed a
little bit I know there are people out
there who don't want to see this movie
because they're like dude it's a remake
it didn't need to be remade the old ones
great I have nostalgic memories wrapped
up in the movie I saw it when I was a
teenager it was cool the old one didn't
have cheesy [ __ ] in it you gotta admit
bro yeah he said that before he punched
a big drill and a guy screwing him need
more proof
yeah that happened in the movie tube
that was cool I just wanted to show that
again that's not one of the cheesy parts
although he was a big animatronic head
that was still cool I'm just saying when
they remake a movie I have to think to
myself could they make a remake that's
better than the old one when I heard
that they were doing a remake of Total
Recall I said that could be really cool
but after seeing this trailer I don't
know if this movie is going to be really
cool I mean Mars isn't in the movie at
all they took it completely out so it
all takes place in this futuristic
version of the United States
alright Colin Farrell's gonna take on
the corrupt government of the feature
those Syfy's are like a dime a dozen
wait a minute then that means there's no
no all right so the Total Recall remake
are you looking forward to it do you
think it's [ __ ] either answer would
be fine as long as it's your true
opinion comment below let me know and as
always if you'd like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more